these two want to be in perfect union
and not only in their workout routine
malintachinda and Odeon are more than
just training Buddies
the pair fell in love 12 years ago and
have been together ever since
three times a week they start their day
with a workout they say it helps their
bodies and their relationships stay in
shape okay
me and my partner are always
on the go all the time working getting
tasks done I think the only time that we
actually can't get to spend together not
as quality time is during our morning
workouts like like today
Woody is a well-known TV presenter in
Thailand for more than a decade he's
been in the public eye
when he came out four years ago it made
big headlines not all of them kind
Woody feels Thailand still has a long
way to go towards full acceptance of
sexual minorities
he welcomes the new bill as an Awakening
for Thai Society
started talking about this seriously
over the past year
attack poof now everyone's like okay
what civil partnership okay so do gays
really need to get married
the conversations out there in a society
that has never talked about this
is a LGBT activist she acknowledges that
a civil union would bring some
improvements for same-sex couples for
example when it comes to succession at
the same time like many activists she
feels the move could entrench their
status as second-class Citizens
if the LIE has been discriminated by its
difficult to set the mind to to create
the mindset for the society to
understand that we are equal so people
will look at us like ah you are a second
citizen because you cannot adopt uh
children you cannot enjoy social welfare
which is it is a huge move far from from
my point of view so instead of taking
baby steps to take some rights I would
go for full rides pool Limited Woody and
oh take a different view they feel
Thailand isn't ready for full marriage
equality demanding all might just result
in achieving nothing
and if you push too hard
you might be aggravating the people
that's living here you know so it's
about knocking the doors or putting the
doors one by one it's the first step I
think it's a very important first step
and if we if we manage to get this first
step right we will still be the very
first in Asia or in Southeast Asia to to
get that and I think uh that that in
it's on its own is such an achievement
both for Thailand for the region it's
something we can be proud of
most of the heavy lifting is done what's
left now is the vote in Parliament
should the civil union bill pass Woody
and oat want to be among the first
same-sex couples in Thailand to legally
tie the knot